I'm going to Disney soon and I wonder if
I should Airbnb there for an extra night
or two oh Disney the next day this ad
for Walt Disney World popped up in my
insta feet could be a coincidence I have
been looking at Disney World rides on my
home computer Instagram's founder denied
the app accesses the microphone to
listen in during an interview with CBS
This Morning anchor Gail King in June
but this is key did you maybe do
something uh with that restaurant in
this example online off of Facebook boom
what you search and interact with in
apps and on the web outside of Instagram
and Facebook are part of your online
data profile we can't say definitively
whether or not they are we haveen